se pencher sur le dernier sujet il nous
reste quelques minutes pour cela je le
disais au début de l'émission
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
est en train de faire examiner sa loi
pacte au parlement cette loi prévoit
notamment des cessions de participations
de l'état
par exemple dans aéroports de paris dans
france dans la française des jeux ou
dans le groupe énergétique
angie est ce que c'est une bonne idée on
a posé la question de façon un peu
direct christophe de voogd faut-il
vendre les bijoux de famille alors
écoutez cette expression laudative pour
le coup les bijoux de famille à propos
de l'entreprise publique devait toujours
un peu sourire parce qu'il ya quand même
c'est à dire voilà parce qu'on a pas mal
de vie joue en toc
en l'occurrence il ya quand même pas mal
d'entreprises publiques allaient je veux
pas être méchant mais je pense à
certaines qui seront très bien difficile
à vendre même même mettre en location au
mont-de-piété donc attention à cette
expression bijoux de famille on a
vraiment se laissait pas le cas en
europe hors de paris c'est mon table je
pense pas démontrable à d'autres
sociétés qui vont très mal d'accord
l'état étant pas vraiment le meilleur
gestionnaire ni le meilleur actionnaire
je dirais même ni le meilleur
actionnaire
vous savez qu'il a tendance à pompe et
ses entreprises et il se comporte bien
plus férocement qu'un fonds de pension
d'autres d'autre part je suis persuadé
que je peux dire ce gros mot sur ce
plateau je peux pas le dire partout mais
étant un libéral vous imaginez que j'ai
tendance à penser que le gouvernement a
autre chose à faire ici à des bijoux de
famille en france et dieu sait qu'il y
en a c'est plutôt le patrimoine et je
crois qu'il faudrait peut-être que le le
gouvernement et l'état assure et pas
seulement par une magnifique effort de
stéphane bern
mais par lui-même l'entretien de nos
vrais bijoux de famille alors on va
écouter un parlementaire qui va tout à
fait dans votre sens c'est charles de
courson est un député centriste c'est
aussi vice président de la commission
des finances de l'assemblée nationale
est pour lui une très bonne idée de
privatiser les entreprises publiques
pour une raison très simple c'est que
l'état ne s'est pas les gérer regardez
le capitalisme d'état a été globalement
un échec en france
échec dans le choix des dirigeants vous
croyez que la patronne d'areva
si ç'avait été une boîte privée aurait
pu faire ce qu'elle a fait qui va coûter
15 milliards aux contribuables français
si tu avais une boîte privée elle aurait
été viré vite fait bien fait par son
conseil d'administration
message personnel à l'attention d'anne
lauvergeon on vous pose la question sur
twitter selon vous l'état doit-il
privatiser nj adp la fdj
vous répondez non à eau a quasiment les
deux tiers et vous guillaume tabard que
répondez vous écoutez je réponds que je
n'ai pas compétence à tous les sujets je
suis pas économiste et pas s'arranger
pas d'avis qui fasse autorité où bon
vous n'avez pas de pollution principe en
tout cas largement devant en principe
spontanément spontanément je me dis que
il n'y a pas de raison que l'état fasse
ce que d'autres peuvent faire à sa place
et peuvent faire mieux je suis assez
sensible parce que dit charles de
courson
je pense que construit des voitures
pas besoin que l'état le
le fasse et d'ailleurs l'état finit par
se désengager des constructeurs
automobiles dans le qualité il était
inquiet qui s'emporte d'autant mieux
voilà alors après dans les entreprises
qu'ils ont cité la notamment à des
pétards et la question c'est est-ce que
d'ayasse entreprise il ya autre chose
simplement qu'une entreprise qui doit
tourner faire des profits pour le point
faible de l'ensemble de l'économie
bonbons que j'en dise d'action les
aéroports c'est aussi une frontière
donc est-ce qu'on peut privatiser une
frontière angie c'est aussi des choix
qui touche aux stratégiques nucléaires
etc
est-ce qu'on peut ben voilà alors après
je pense que c'est à l'état aussi de
définir dans des cahiers des charges
jacente de deux principes de règles de
garde fou est aussi deux derniers points
lorsque la logique cyniquement la l'état
qui cherche à tout prix de l'argent si
c'est juste pour grappiller un peu de un
peu d'euros et diminuer les déficits
c'est insuffisant si c'est au service
d'une vraie vision in d'une raie
stratégie sur l'économie
tout peut se défendre alors vous adp ou
aéroports de paris où la française des
jeux
ce sont aussi des monopoles et ceux qui
sont hostiles aux privatisations donne
par exemple exemple des autoroutes
n'importe qui peut pas créer une
autoroute en disant regardez on les a
privatisé le résultat des courses c'est
que ça coûte un bras aux français quand
ils veulent les prendre
matteo csel verte si vous avez un point
de vue sur ce sujet c'est je pense aux
autoroutes moment je pense à âge n 7
était autoroute privatiser un état dit
aussi on a eu pas mal de privatisations
à partir des années 90 c'était très
grande je pense que
pour privatiser il faut penser d'abord à
la possibilité de faire des économies
dans le conseil d'état la cour des
comptes mardi le suggérer mais aussi au
fait qu' il faut être sûr que d'ici 20
ans ces enfants structure et ses joyaux
de famille bijoux de famille ne soit pas
effectivement nécessaire a affirmé une
sorte d'autorité aussi sur un certain
territoire qui est le territoire d'un
état donc peut-être une voie possible
c'est celle de créer une espèce de fond
peut-être entre certains pays
peut-être le niveau européen et c'est
aussi pour se protéger un peu plus
vis-à-vis des concurrents chinois et
américains je n'ai pas les compétences
pour dire à quelle est la forme
juridique de ce type d'institution mais
disons que si les états effectivement
pouvait se libérer de quelque chose qui
est lourd mais qui restait quelque part
aux services de leur as de leurs
systèmes infrastructure al ça serait pas
mal
huit meilleurs vous avez un point de vue
sur moi je suis pour les privatisations
à condition qu'une garantie ferme et
éthiques
autant dire que ça sera comme pour les
autoroutes par exemple c est aussi comme
pour les partenariats public-privé dont
on s'aperçoit que dans ces situations
dans ces partenariats
le public c'est georges d'onde et donc
non je suis désolé mais on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui en tout cas sans compter la
question des aéroports aucun aéroport
américain ni intérieure ni à la
frontière n'est privatiser ils sont tous
publics dans ses chansons dans lost il
m'en a vraiment il y mène 3-1 n'a même
pas que n'a pas proposé de privatiser
les aéroports donc en l'état actuel la
fois d'ailleurs aussi pour la raison que
vous avez dit parce qu'on a vraiment
l'impression que il faut à tout prix la
retrouver quelque chose parce que sinon
on va pas pouvoir les récupérer au
mont-de-piété la vieille normande et
donc non c'est pas possible tu entends
qu on a affaire a alors certes
évidemment l'état n'est sans doute pas
d'exemple d'areva extrêmement puissant
et du crédit lyonnais avant et après et
ailleurs non et non seulement crédit
lyonnais et mais commençons par faire en
sorte que l'état réforme sans son
utilisation de la dépense publique est
peut-être après on peut songer avant
mais là en l'état on a on on perd sur
les deux tableaux
je vais vous répondre quelles garanties
c'est vrai que c'est un peu une solution
de facilité dont on disait alors c'est
mieux en anglais mais on dirait la
naissance anglaise qui dit vendre
l'argenterie pour payer le boucher
cc c'est pas forcément comme ça qu'on
gère bien un pays mais ça c'est toujours
les questions de l'étatisme français qui
se portent aussi bien à droite qu'à
gauche mais je rappelle quand même sur
l'autoroute que des autoroutes juste une
précision
j'ai pas le souvenir que l est pas qu
ils étaient publiques elle était si bon
marché et je constate et tout le monde
le pense
at tout le monde constate c'est que la
qualité du service depuis qu'elles sont
privatisés s'est énormément amélioré
notamment les aires autoroutières et ça
il faut il faut donc faire un peu la
part des choses deuxièmement en matière
de sécurité du transport
alors là les statistiques sont
impitoyables les chemins de fer qui ont
les meilleurs taux de sécurité en europe
sur les chemins de fer privés
c'est le chemin de fer britannique et le
chemin de fer suisses donc et la sncf
malheureusement vous parlez de gênes
vous avez raison mais les accidents cf
la grande différence entre le privé et
le public c'est qu'il n'ya tant que
public poules avait rappelé là je le
filme et hier il n'y a jamais de
responsables jamais guillaume tabac
c'est encore un marqueur de droite
la privatisation ou bien comme tout le
monde en fait aujourd'hui c'est une
mesure de gestion comme une autre octo
oui ça fait longtemps je pense que ce
n'est plus un clivage gauche droite le
le dernier grand combat idéologique
c'est elle c'est début des années 80
mitterrand qui nationalise en 81 et
chirac qui privatise en 86 depuis tous
les gouvernements y ont eu recours
et je crois même rôle que le record de
présentation c'est sous le nom de jospin
vraiment de l'allemande droite ce qu'on
peut simplement espérer comme
contribuable c'est que l'état vende au
bon prix et qu'ils ne se fassent pas
avoir parce que la cour des comptes
encore elle a relevé dans le passé un
certain nombre d'affaires qui ont été
meilleurs pour les acheteurs privés que
pour les vendeurs public voilà point de
vue c'est fini pour ce soir merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre d'y avoir
participé
vous retrouvez à ce même endroit demain
à la même heure marie-amélie l'amba
bonsoir
[Musique]